sous une feuille de plastique blanc le
corps de georges besse le pdg de renault
le patron de la régie a été assassiné au
moment même où il rentrait chez lui son
chauffeur venait de le déposer
il était aux environs de 20 heures
immédiatement les hommes de la brigade
criminelle commencé leur enquête et
premier indice les projets qu'il
retrouvait à deux pas de l'attentât et
bien sûr les témoignages des voisins
bon j'ai entendu quelques coups de feu
et ce qui s'est passé c'est que bon
genre est en sorti parce que j'ai cru
d'abord que c'était un pétard d'une
comme ça mais j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
deux personnes qui s'enfuyaient
bon j'ai vu une personne avec une veste
bleue qui s'enfuit du côté à droite
alors est-ce une pierre est cette
personne il ya une deux autres personnes
qui étaient partis je crois qu'ils
veulent non une femme à merde qu'il a vu
a dit que c'était un homme une femme
viendra besoins parlent de deux femmes
et d'un homme en moto jacques chirac le
premier ministre est arrivé sur les
lieux très rapidement en compagnie de
robert pandraud le ministre chargé de la
sécurité publique
ils sont allés saluer la famille de
monsieur baisse qui peut avoir signé cet
attentat pour l'instant non revendiquée
selon les enquêteurs très certainement
action directe peut être même avec
l'aide de la fraction armée rouge
allemand et policiers affirment qu'il
s'attendait à une action terroriste
une autre personnalité s'était même vu
attribuer ces derniers jours une
protection rapprochée
les autorités semblent donc avoir été
surprise par la cible choisie par les
terroristes
george best était à la tête de la régie
renault depuis janvier 85
il avait d'abord été l'un des patrons du
nucléaire français à la dette d'eurodif
et de la cogema et puis ensuite il avait
dirigé pechiney enfin ils avaient été
appelés donc en 85 à la tête de la régie
renault pour redresser une situation
difficile jean pierre métivier
c'est en sauveur que georges besse
arrive à la tête de la régie renault en
chantier 85
l'entreprise à 12 milliards de pertes
lui a une solide réputation de
gestionnaire acquise chez péchiney
georges besse à 58 ans c'est aussi un
des grands hommes du nucléaire l'ex
président de la cogema il a construit
pierrelatte et tricastin à la régie il
surprend tout le monde en se taisant
pendant un an
il ne dit rien il travaille il
n'intervient qu'au rythme des séances
des comités d'entreprise
cela lui vaut l'hostilité des syndicats
de la régie et aussi des militants
communistes qui l'interpellent ici sur
les champs elysées à la sortie d'un
conseil d'administration
pourtant c'est lui qui décide les
premiers licenciements secs chez renault
qui reprend en main le réseau commercial
et qui réussit ces derniers mois une
remontée des ventes mais également lors
du dernier salon il pouvait annoncer que
les pertes de la régie n'atteindrait que
5 milliards et demi cette année la
chance lui souriait lui aussi avait
retrouvé son sourire
il avait même donné rendez vous aux
enfants elle est très agréable parce que
ça permet de rouler comme on veut
cigarettes seule revendication à
l'époque un tract retrouvé le 17
novembre au soir au métro raspail
quelques heures auparavant georges besse
avait été abattu devant son domicile
action directe signé cet attentat
commando pierre overney mais les
enquêteurs noter qu'à aucun moment le
nom du pdg de renault n'était cité de
plus le tract était une photocopie et
les experts ne pouvait établir avec
certitude l'origine de la machine à
écrire
aujourd'hui c'est dans ce texte de 26
pages qu action directe explicite son
attentat le commando qui a gouverné dit
le groupe clandestin à frapper au coeur
même de la contradiction la plus forte
au sein du consensus général de
pacification et d'exploitation prose
habituel du groupe décortiqué dès à
présent par les services de police
trois jours après l'attentât les photos
de nathalie ménigon et de joëlle aubron
étaient envoyés dans tous les
commissariats de france leur portrait
placardés dans paris l'anc est pourtant
n'a guère progressé depuis novembre deux
femmes ont été vues sur les lieux du
crime
mais rien ne permet encore aujourd'hui
d'affirmer qu'il s'agit d' obrou et de
ménigot bonsoir jean marc rouillan
nathalie ménigon joëlle aubron
georges cipriani arrêté hier soir vers
21h sont considérés comme les chefs
historiques du mouvement terroriste
action directe cette arrestation groupe
et sans effusion de sang est un succès
pour la police tout entière et pas
seulement pour les hommes de l'unité
d'élite qui sont intervenus hier sur la
commune de vitry aux loges dans le
département du loiret les quatre
militants d'action directe se trouvait
dans une ferme isolée
voici avec emmanuel vanier jean
corneille et dominique thiel les
conditions reconstitué de l'opération
policière
voici la ferme où jean marc rouillan et
nathalie ménigon les deux chefs
historiques d'action directe
ainsi que joëlle aubron et georges
cipriani ont été arrêtés hier soir une
opération parfaitement menée par les
policiers du raid recherche assistance
intervention dissuasion avec à leur tête
le commissaire prend j'mende fini il y à
la plus de 50 policiers du raid et 30
membres des renseignements généraux
hier dans la journée il cerne la ferme
et identifie formellement nathalie
ménigon
20h55 l'assaut dans la ferme la surprise
est totale de membres d'action directe
tente de s'enfuir par les fenêtres les
policiers tirent en l'air les quatre
terroristes sont arrêtés une enquête
était en cours depuis plusieurs semaines
une prime d'un million de francs avait
été offerte à tout informateur vendredi
les policiers recouper deux informations
capitales
il mettait alors en place leur
dispositif autour de la plante des
terroristes lors de la perquisition les
policiers ont découvert un véritable
arsenal un fusil d'assaut 30 kg
d'explosif 80 détonateur et du matériel
d'écouté très sophistiqué de nombreux
documents ont également été saisis
notamment des listes de personnalités à
enlever ou à tuer et surtout les
policiers ont découvert l'original de la
revendication de l'assassinât de georges
besse l'ancien président directeur
général de renault a battu en novembre
dernier à paris par deux femmes se
réclamant d'action directe
les policiers vont maintenant épluché
ses documents et analyser les armes et
les munitions
ils vont notamment les comparer aux
douilles retrouvées près du corps de
georges besse dans la ferme six pièces
l'une d'elles a été aménagé en prison
populaire les enquêteurs pensent qu
action directe projetaient d'enlever
prochainement une personnalité
importante dans le village c'est la
stupéfaction depuis trois ans on
connaissait bien rouillan et ménigon qui
se faisait appeler nadine des voisins
tranquille est plutôt sympathique dit on
vous voyez le plus souvent c'était une
amie qui venait ici trop fort semaine
presque trois semaines au ravitaillement
les chercher du lait mais deux fois et
venez pourriez faire voler nous voulons
dire bonjour et puis des fois vous des
galères grammaire 88 ans la survie et à
cause d'elle travail était sympathique
vraiment gentille vraiment hier dans ce
petit village de l'orléanais c'est donc
une longue traque de plus de 4 ans qui a
pris fin depuis hier ce sont donc tous
les responsables présumés d'action
directe qui sont en prison jean marc
rouillan nathalie ménigon joëlle aubron
georges cipriani suivantes ainsi régis
schleicher détenu est accusé du meurtre
de deux policiers avenue trudaine c'est
donc un coup très sévère porté aux
mouvements d'action directe
né il y a huit ans mouvement hétérogène
qui n'a cessé de dériver vers les
actions les plus sanglantes en france en
liaison avec d'autres groupes
terroristes européen
l'histoire d'action directe résumé est
expliquée par hervé brusini et dominique
tierces de la publicité pour action
directe
en plein paris nous sommes en décembre
81 rouillan ménigon et tous les membres
du groupe sont dans les rues
ils ont été initiés quelques mois plus
tôt dans les immeubles insalubres du
xviiie arrondissement
ils jouent les assistantes sociales
défendre la cause des immigrés parle à
la télé action directe au grand jour
cela ne durera pas longtemps et chef
historique vient de la clandestinité
ils vont y retourner jean marc rouillan
d'abord à 18 ans il se donne le nom de
guerre ce basse et disparaît pour
militer au sein du gari le groupe
d'action révolutionnaire
internationaliste avec le gari il signe
ses premiers attentats dans le sud ouest
de la france
c'est l'époque de la solidarité avec les
espagnols antifranquistes nathalie
ménigon elle vient de l'extrême gauche
l'ancien employé de banque a choisi les
rangs de l'autonomie barres de fer
cocktails molotov casque de motard
l'option violence comme projet politique
en 79 ménigon et rouillan fonds d'action
directe
ce couple va devenir l'obsession des
policiers quatre ou cinq personnes
composent le groupe au début mais très
vite dans leur sillage elle entraîne une
centaine de sympathisants action
symbolique les cibles ministère et
magasins de luxe brusque coup d'arrêt en
81 la rue pergolèse nathalie ménigon et
ceinturé par les hommes des
renseignements généraux
elles viennent vider son chargeur sur
les policiers en hurlant je suis action
directe à ses côtés rouillan lui aussi
est arrêté tous les deux resteront un an
sous les verrous avant de profiter de la
loi d'aministie 1982 dans ce parking
les policiers découvrent un arsenal
action directe s'est réarmé fusil à
pompe et pistolets mitrailleurs grenades
offensives
c'est joëlle aubron qui les a mis sur
cette piste sans le vouloir elle est
arrêté et relâché dix huit mois plus
tard
joëlle aubron la fille de bonne famille
une proche du couple
rouillan ménigon à eux trois ils forment
le noyau dur d'action directe ils
commettront plusieurs braquages avec
leurs complices
cipriani ils sont l'essentiel de la
branche internationaliste d'action
directe 1984 les débuts de l'euro
terrorisme vaste offensive contre l'otan
plusieurs bombes sont placés sur le
réseau les eaux du pacte atlantique les
policiers au sentiment que les
clandestins sont décidément
insaisissable et ce qu'il redoutait
annoncé au grand jour le mariage entre
les français d'action directe et les
allemands de la fraction armée rouge
mais aussi les belges des cellules
communistes combattantes les ccc
85 nouvelle escalade de la violence les
assassinats 1 comme audran l'ingénieur
général de l'armement deux tentatives
ensuite contre le général blanc d'un
contrôleur des armées et guy branagh
vice président du patronat
enfin georges besse le pdg de renault
abattu devant son domicile principaux
suspects joëlle aubron nathalie ménigon
dans le texte de revendication de cet
attentat action directe annoncé ses
prochaines cibles
les sections spéciales chargées de la
lutte antiterroriste aujourd'hui c'est
devant tel que devront s'expliquer
rouillan et ses complices
à des actions directes c'était toile
rouge à cinq branches apparaît pour la
première fois en 79 attentat contre le
ministère du travail à paris
c'est le temps des cibles symboliques
banque ambassades sociétés
internationales action directe
si le groupe a choisi ce nom c'est parce
que dans sa première période son but est
d'agir en dehors des partis et les
syndicats
le gauchisme français s'étiole et se
terminent de l'année soit 475 et les
politiques et le schisme violent parce
qu'il décide de le faire de ce discours
pas sombrer dans le terrorisme et que
c'est à peu près de ce moment là des
années soixante seize que les gens qui
plus tard vont faire actions directes
commencent à venir à l'action politique
à la conscience politique si on peut
appeler ça l'action politique et il y
rencontrera contre-courant à contretemps
et à contre société pour sortir de cet
isolement action directe cherche un
soutien hors de france
liaison avec les fraction armée rouge en
allemagne les brigades rouges en italie
les cellules communistes combattantes en
belgique
c'est alors le début de la période dure
1984 hold up de l'avenue trudaine de
police situé meurtre du général audran
attentat manqué contre guy branagh le
vice président du cnpf assassinats de
georges besse le pdg de renault le
groupe préparait d'autres attentats
après la rafle de vitry aux loges on a
trouvé ici des armes des explosifs et la
liste de futures cibles alors la
question se pose ce coup de filet du 21
février 87 marque-t-il la chute d'action
directe
l'action clandestine requiert un certain
nombre de personnes
on sait que pour faire une filature il
faut tant de gens pour poser une bombe
autant de gens pour tuer une personne il
faut tant de gens et ce qui était fait
au nom d'action directe par les gens
dont le nom le central est et vitry aux
loges dépasse les capacités de travail
de quatre personnes même acharné même ne
faisant que ça donc il est certain qu'à
l'heure actuelle des complices des
comparses des gens
de la logistique par exemple sont sans
doute encore en liberté et il reste il
doit rester quelques plans quelques
appartements conspiratif comme dit la
police qui n'ont pas été trouvés il y a
deux jours le juge bruguière spécialiste
du terrorisme recevait une lettre de
menaces signés action directe canular
véritable menace ou l'utilisation du
sigle il est trop tôt pour savoir si
l'étoile d'action directe s'est éteinte
définitivement